they saw you cuz you do all the things
you want me to tears
you know it's weird Amazon exactly a
year ago today
oh really yeah [__] nominal across
the street [__] oh [__]
you [__] cleaner than a good
time cuz it's a full schedule the night
[__] oh [__]
[Music]
my ac/dc on
by the time my friends are gonna be
there - oh [__] on the highway - [__]
hell you know why the devil showing up
that's why [__] a full bag we're
going [__] 800 maybe 9 right off the
bat that's right we go through what the
professionals here win got time for
okey-doke no stop sign speed limit was
deemed arrays right right away he's on
the drums forget about it oh [__]
I found all these stars in my travel bag
it was the harlot if you've been into
this [__] thing you're too performer
I paid my Duke he shows up now he's out
there yet but we're dropping these
[__] edibles quick here chef what
fool
three
[Music]
mmm don't stop man oh [__] here we go
check that [__] meal got some
good weed
Larry og from perennial this is this
shipment is named after my boy in Vegas
talking [__] talking hope poking laughs
hmm these edibles are delicious tonight
you said
hi way the hell I'm on a high oh [__]
are you coming with me [__] up this
breakup the sleeping pills tell grandma
it's over you gotta borrow two [__]
sleeping pills till next Thursday but
right now we're gonna keep smoking this
[__] reefer till the devil shows up
Saint Lazarus here everybody's [__]
here except you people you um saying so
get your [__] together one of the
greatest downs of our time Highway to
Hell 1979
bon Scott's last [__] masterpiece and
you're sitting there talking to me about
Axl Rose it's me playing I don't give a
[__] I wouldn't listen to that [__] if
you [__] paid me this is the easy
peasy I want to [__] hear start to
see the devil [__] it's Wednesday
night Oh Jay made in America uncle Joey
made in America understand me
oh yeah Oh [__] yeah if you ain't
gonna see the devil uncle Joey you're
never gonna [__] see the devil and if
you don't see the devil then you'll
never know your [__] God does that
make sense to you I thought it did
that I thought bad down
she's enough to style landslide what
just a walking down the street oh [__]
[Music]
now you're warming right there look at
Lee going deep into the murky waters of
edibles f1 they go no [__] around Lee
there you go oh [__] before just like
that look look up see you could be that
happy - jumping up and down shaving your
hand look smoother than a [__]
right there
[Laughter]
you bet [__] I just build my
weed but no worries we got more and we
got a week's tour around the pond that's
open till 8:00 never [__] close as
long as you got an Armenian friend you
understand me if you don't have an
Armenian friend full of gun in your
[__] mouth right now cuz your life
ain't gonna pan out feed Armenians are
the reason why I'm [__] here reefer
insurance fraud they might type of
people you understand me I gotta get a
new light of this [__] little line
[__] half a mighty calling lighter
here is look at this splinter
[__] just [__] light up the
girls got rhythm the girls got rhythm
what's up leader right there see bumble
Joey always has a backup real mother
will [__] reefer heads always have
ten [__] backups
if not I'll rub my post together like
that fungi on fire help me I don't give
a [__] jack [__] the Boy Scouts I've
made fire is that a [__] insulation
by itself
are you kidding me a woman you people
want to deal with uncle Joey's the rest
of these okie Doug's hi I'm high they
fake it love you
this is flavor [__] coming at you the
wreck he go Lisa I get your party
started from thank you sir look at leave
[Music]
he promises wrong it is the double wheel
radius bone is the [__] Larry talking
where smoke we're looking back tonight
[__] whistle questions I don't
know you hope you hit them you tell one
what do you want hit Louie in another
one [__] in the house trying to be
quiet Wednesday mother [__] if you
ain't alive you better be alive now cuz
we're coming at you [__] full force
and [__] what time is it people stop
like are you kidding me alone 7:45 and
all is well 10:45 on the East Coast [__]
that the night show
oh [__] here we go [__] walk all over
you Derek Carly's got he's got a [__]
watch and a thing for a [__] Eagle to
land on he's
why am i smoking with this brain liner
you [__] the Talmud is open
gazing look at at least like how do you
get that to smoke that much
you got a smoke [__] you got
expand those lungs
you gotta hold your breath for a minute
I haven't held my breath for 10 [__]
seconds there's no reason these seas
here
get your [__] doughnuts whatever you
need to do to get your head together cuz
we're going deep tonight where's those
stars me and Leah split another one
we're going in and we're going for 900
tonight cuz we ain't [__] around and
I suggest you do the [__] same
[__] ain't got time for this [__]
no more with you [__] you're
gonna get deep or [__] and go hang out
with one of these other [__] [__]
comments there you go son Ben Adina baby
what - honey afternoon oh [__] you
Darren Carl you're looking around like a
[__]
now I've got the physical that's weak
oh this [__] wait for an
earthquake oh [__] you know the
earthquake is that's the same flash
there's gonna be flashed in these
eyeballs tonight that make sure he's
coming back from [__] the dead
we don't need vital signs here as long
as you got a [__] hard-on you're on
top oh yeah I love you [__]
always you know that we go deep Ian I
got your back you got mine okay I'm with
you you're with me and they're with us
and we're gonna keep growing the church
is coming at you like [__] ten black
dudes in Memphis we're going strong and
I'm saying I ain't got time to be
[__] around we ain't get it's over
I'm down you're right now
Philadelphia's so [__] out because of
you [__] that's why I love you
[__] done
you guys don't [__] around in Philly
they get the weapons they think they
they beat people in the head it's like
Mad Max we're going deep
oh sure here we go [__] Angus Young
79 look here we go he ain't stopping and
this is all on herbal tea no blow no
nothing
[Music]
what's ugly please sitting there
thinking about what's gonna be like in
two hours you don't know we still have
another star waiting and the [__] the
stratosphere cuz that's how we do it if
you're an amateur go hang out with
somebody else
the only want professionals yeah we're
like the [__] Marines alright this is
the US Marine of reefers training
facility right here Lisa at is the first
[__] graduate
[Music]
don't forget me Willie Barcena Tommy's
submission factory Saturday night 8
o'clock
if Willie's there you might as well
bring the [__] headgear cuz it's all
over [__] I'm gonna walk all over you
it was Dean dubbing oh [__] oh [__] we
go it was one of those nights when we
turned out the lights and I stuck it up
in your muffler here we go [__]
it's over put the robe on [__] coming
at you [__] Jimmy Falon [__] Conan
they don't do this [__] that I'm
throwing he that [__] we got guests we
got lights [__] the music man who needs
them [__] we got it off we got
a whole music we write our own books
[Music]
the uncle joey's out of his [__] mind
but he loves you my son Young Saeng
uncle joey's out of his mind but he
loves you that's all that [__]
matters right along what's those must
exactly I can feel in here 900 the stem
in them saying it's over Felice ayat
you'll be sleeping here till Friday
[__] morning Paulo be texting them
he'll be voices oh [__] anyway we're
gonna start this podcast and ten [__]
minutes we'll be on YouTube right or
wrong don't forget Darren Carter's new
CD is on pre-sale all right
go to iTunes I don't know the [__]
name but no names just Darren car that's
all you need to [__] know man that's
all you need to know Darren Carter go to
iTunes right now retune whatever [__]
you need to do uncle Joey [__] I love
you [__] we'll be back in 10
minutes ready to rock I don't wanna hear
those stories all right stay black was
deemed Oh